der bundestag der oberster gesetzgeber
ist unzufrieden mit den runden den
pandemie runden wie sie bisher gelaufen
sind das ist ja auch kein wunder nach
den vorfällen in dieser woche und es ist
genau ein jahr her dass sich das erste
mal die bund länder runde bei der
bundeskanzlerin zur pandemie bekämpfung
besprechung wird getroffen hat und in
dieser woche kam es dann zum super-gau
eigentlich nur in anführungsstrichen
einen handwerks fehler aber der wird
natürlich viele fragen auf und in der
tat viele abgeordnete des bundestages
nicht nur der opposition fordern dass
der bundestag mehr beteiligt wird man
muss noch mal klar sagen der bundestags
die legislative bundesregierung und die
länderchefs sind die exekutive jeweils
und die legislative hat ja vorgelegt den
rahmen in dem sich diese exekutive
bewegen kann man hat auch noch mal
nachgebessert indem man 17 maßnahmen in
das infektionsgeschehen aufgenommen hat
aufgenommen hat also so ganz frei können
die bundeskanzlerin die
ministerpräsidenten sich nicht bewegen
aber das reicht den parlamentariern
nicht und darüber möchte ich jetzt reden
mit den beiden parlamentarischen ersten
parlamentarischen geschäftsführern der
spd und der fdp carsten schneider und
marco buschmann
herr schneider ich hab's gesagt ist
nicht gut gelaufen hat jeder mitgekriegt
die unzufriedenheit ist auch sehr groß
hier im hause muss denn eigentlich der
bundestag wirklich über jede einzelne
entscheidung mit beraten sowie das die
ein oder andere oppositionsfraktion
jetzt hier fordert nein also beraten der
bundestag kann sowieso machen was er
will und die mehrheit des bundestags
entscheidet dass die grundsätzliche
aufgabenteilung in deutschland ist aber
so dass wir den rahmen setzen die
gesetze die sind gemacht dass wir auch
einschreiten können wenn wir es wollen
und notwendig erachten
und dann setzt bei der exekutive die
ausführung viktor ließ in deutschland
über die länder mit verteilt und dort im
übrigen gibt es eine rückkoppelung auch
in den landtag was die einzelnen
verordnungen betrifft ob es
einschränkungen ausgangs verrenkungen gc
gibt von daher das ist mehr eine debatte
der form nach die aber meines erachtens
der dynamik der infektionsgeschehen
nicht gerecht wird ich würde lieber über
die frage wie kommen wir weiter runter
von den zahlen sprechen da scheint mir
insgesamt die
die nach diesen wirkliche verkorksten
bund länder treffen so ein bisschen der
erwartung da zu sein das ist aber nicht
über die kinder wenn ich sehe dass
gestern im saarland entschieden hat die
kinos wieder öffnen zu wollen so hat es
das passt nicht in die zeit und ich
verstehen uns unbenommen und zwar zu
melden oder eben auch einzugreifen
bisher sehe ich denke ich habe solche
auch 1 punkt klargemacht für die
spd-fraktion die kanzlerin wollte gern
prüfen ob es auslandsreise verbot gibt
oder dass man das machen kann ich gesagt
das machen wir nicht weil das nicht
verhältnismäßig ist bekannt gericht
standhalten wird es gibt mildere mittel
die testpflicht für unternehmen also wie
die arbeitnehmerinnen unternehmen und so
greifen wir da schon ein herr buschmann
die fdp fordert ja viel fangen wir mal
bei der hauptforderung an die auch herr
lindner schon seit monaten erhebt dass
die kanzlerin sich vorher hier im
bundestag äußert bevor sie mit den
ministerpräsidenten berät eigentlich
eine sache die kann man gut
nachvollziehen wir haben das gestern zum
beispiel gesehen sie tut das ja zum
beispiel wenn man es in brüssel
sitzungen gibt dann äussert sie sich
meistens hier aber richtig einfluss kann
die opposition ja dann auf die
entscheidungswege auch nicht nehmen ja
doch denn es gibt ja nicht nur die
aufgabe des bundestages als technischer
gesetzgeber tätig zu werden also die
technische gesetzesmaterie zu
beschließen sondern wir sind hier auch
ein forum der willensbildung und ich
möchte sagen ein forum der
qualitätssicherung was heißt das wir
haben gesehen dass wenn nachts in
kleiner runde übermüdet im ganz kleinen
kreise entschieden wird dass es dann zu
fehlern kommt das ist erst mal
menschlich aber der parlamentarismus hat
ja mechanismen um solche fehlerquellen
zu minimieren beispielsweise das
gegenspiel von regierung und tragenden
kräften und opposition
und ich behaupte ein solcher vorschlag
wie in die kanzlerin da gemacht hat der
sicher übrigens nicht im rahmen dessen
bewegt was die exekutive schon darf es
fehlten jahr rechtsgrundlagen der
feiertage einführen will muss feiertags
gesetze ändern
ein solcher fehler wäre der hätte keine
arbeitsgruppe einer fraktion im
parlament überstanden ich behaupte
keine fünf minuten wäre der vorschlag in
einer arbeitsgruppe arbeit und soziales
bei der spd hätte er überlebt zumindest
wer sofort die frage gestellt wie soll
das gehen wer bezahlt das und deshalb
ist es besser die dinge im parlament zu
beraten weil wir hier sorgfältiger
beraten können und qualitätssicherungs
mechanismen haben die grünen fordern
einen pandemie rat und die fraktionen
spd und cdu/csu arbeiten an einem
parlamentarischen begleitet gremium ist
das was anderes und was soll das regeln
was im kern ist es so dass wir in der
nächsten sitzungswoche etwas machen was
wir schon vorher hätten machen müssen
und auch sollen nämlich ein
sondergremium bundestag zu schaffen das
interdisziplinär angelegt ist also von
verschiedenen arbeitsgruppen sowie herr
buschmann das gesagt hat aber ein
soziales gesundheit bildung und
forschung die köpfe zusammenzustecken
und die unterschiedlichen vorlagen der
regierung also welche entscheidungen
trifft sie testregionen etc
es gibt ja ein extra kabinett corona
kabinett nennt sich dass das muss
stärker gespiegelt werden auch im
bundestag selbst das sage ich jetzt mal
kritik an uns das hätten wir schon
früher machen müssen
machen wir jetzt aber und auch dort soll
es die das was die grünen dort sich
vorstellen ihre also externe
wissenschaftler hinzu ziehen kann dort
und wird dort auch mit stattfindet im
übrigen aber auch jetzt schon in
unterschiedlichen ausschüssen anhörung
etc stadt ist dann aber nicht so
gebündelt
das ist die die form der bündelung wo
ich mir von versprechern auch für mich
jetzt als führung einer fraktion eine
stärkere meinungsbildung und eben auch
einzulaufen informationen gebündelt
haben und nicht sich das aus allen
möglichen bereichen zu holen von daher
ist das glaube ich schon eine stärkung
ich will aber ein punkt muss man sagen
mit den mechanismen
ich bin skeptisch ich glaube auch nicht
dass es die aufgabe des bundestages ist
mit 709 abgeordneten unterschiedlichster
fraktionen auch in den fraktionen gibt
es sehr unterschiedliche meinungen und
auffassungen welche schritte jetzt
notwendig werden um die mehr zu werden
dass das einfacher wäre oder auch
schneller um entscheidung zu treffen als
das mit 16 ministerpräsidentin und
erkannt so hannes das glaube ich nicht
und zumindest die unsere seite sowie spd
seitig sind die vorbereitung auch ein
geboten der entscheidung
die erste diese feiertags nicht die kam
erst später aber es ist ein kern
exekutive frage das begleit gremium da
muss ich natürlich nachfragen was sie
davon halten und sie haben es gerade
angesprochen die einzelnen maßnahmen 17
sind ja festgelegt worden
natürlich könnte man sagen der bundestag
hat die freiheit jetzt noch mehr
maßnahmen festzulegen damit der rahmen
für die die letztlich entscheiden die
exekutive etwas deutlicher gesteckt wird
ja das sind sie mich drei anmerkungen
machen erstens eine antwort auf herrn
schneider
ich behaupte nicht dass es leichter wird
aber die ergebnisse werden besser wenn
man mehr meinungen mehr argumente in die
entscheidung einbeziehen werden die
entscheidungen besser und ich glaube das
ist der anspruch den die bürgerinnen und
bürger in einer solchen krisensituation
haben möglichst gute entscheidungen zu
bekommen weil wir nicht gibt es eben
chaos wie jetzt zweite anmerkung
pandemie hre hat ich glaube falsch wäre
es zu glauben man könnte politik durch
fachleute ersetzen also diejenigen die
glauben man gibt die entscheidung an
experten und die politik sollte sich
raushalten
das führt auch zu falschen ergebnissen
weil man nicht mit technokratie ein volk
mit 80 mit über 80 millionen menschen
erfolgreich regieren können es ist immer
wieder schief gegangen allerdings
expertise interdisziplinäre expertise
hinzuzuziehen das ist richtig das findet
ihr übrigens auch stadt beispielsweise
in nordrhein westfalen hat die
schwarz-gelbe landesregierungen ja genau
ein solches expertengremium eingesetzt
und die dritte anmerkung sie haben das
infektionsschutzgesetz eingesprochen
schauen sie der mangel des
infektionsschutzgesetzes sind ja nicht
die auflistung der 17 maßnahmen der
mangel das infektionsschutzgesetz ist
dass man gar nicht genau weiß wann sie
zulässig sind und zwar nicht weil die
die juristen sprechen vom tatbestand
also von den voraussetzungen wann das
zulässig ist sind so wolkig sind so
offen so unbestimmt formuliert dass in
der rechtswissenschaft große
verunsicherung herrscht wann das
zulässig sind das heißt einfach nur eins
man weiß es nicht in welcher situation
welche maßnahmen ergriffen wird
infektionsschutzgesetz die maßnahmen
sind wohl
das ist ja eine direkte kritik am
eigenen haus hier nämlich der bundestag
hat das festgelegt die regierung
tragenden fraktionen sind ja
verantwortlich sind diese 17 maßnahmen
zu wolkig sind sie zu breit gefasste
muss der gesetzgeber der exekutive einen
engeren rahmen geben
wir haben glaube ich schon in relativ
engen rahmen und das zusammenspiel und
auch die checks and balances zwischen
regierung parlamenten und gerichten
funktioniert weil wir sehr oft auch
entscheidungen haben so schlecht
begründete verordnungsentwürfe aus den
ländern auch korrigiert werden
system brauchen auch durchaus stolz sein
kann in deutschland das wenn die berater
rechtsgrundlage die wir als gesetzgeber
des bundes will ausnahmen gab er bei dem
einzelhandels haben wir das ganz
korrigiert und die mitsprache der
parlamente sollen einmal einzig
vergessen gibt auch landtage und die
landtage haben unterschiedliche
mechanismen ob sie selbst diesen
vorschlägen verordnung der
landesregierung zustimmen müssen und nur
erst dann in kraft tritt oder ob sie nur
zur kenntnis genommen werden als das
gibt es ja auch dass ihr nicht nur der
bundestag tätig ist es gibt eben ein
sehr unterschiedliches einfach
infektionsgeschehen manche länder oder
städte da habe ich eine inzidenz von 50
manchmal mit von 500 bei mir in
thüringen brauche ich andere andere
entscheidung und die könnte ich gar
nicht ganz ehrlich nicht hier im
bundestag festlegen ob ich ein kreis mit
einer 550er incidents schulen schließen
oder ob ich das in weimar mit einer 70er
eben nicht machen geschäfte öffnen so
und deswegen ist es die zentrale glaube
schon ganz gut
herr schneider sie angesprochen einen
vorteil unseres staates ist das
föderative system muss man natürlich
nach dem chaos dieser woche auch ein
bisschen hinterfragen starts richter
diskutieren da auch die bundeskanzlerin
hat eigentlich die jure betrachtet kaum
eine einflussmöglichkeit bei diesen
beratungen sie kann das ganze versuchen
zu bündeln aber qua verordnungen sind es
ja hinter die ministerpräsidenten in
ihren 16 bundesländern die hinterher
machen was sie wollen sagt ich mal weil
es meistens nicht geklappt hat also das
ist eines der kernprobleme und da kommt
der eine oder andere stadtrechte auf die
idee und sagte
der bundestag wenn er denn schon sagt
wir wollen mehr beteiligt werden könnte
natürlich radikale maßnahmen auf fahren
und sagen
demnächst werden wir per gesetz ist so
ordnen dass die bundesregierung als
einziges zu entscheiden hat demnächst
wie diese maßnahmen außer bildung und
polizei demnächst vor ort durchgeführt
werden müssen also ich bin nicht dieser
ansicht
ich glaube dass und das haben wir ja
auch von anfang an gesagt dass die
regionalisierte betrachtungsweise also
auf das konkrete infektionsgeschehen vor
ort zu schauen
richtig ist um dann die geeigneten
maßnahmen zu finden
das ist nicht nur eine frage der
subsidiarität und der des föderalen
systems sondern dass sie auch eine frage
der verhältnismäßigkeit weil man eben
nicht eine stadt mit einer 200er
incidents mit einer 20er inzidenz über
einen kamm scheren kann
deshalb finde ich die regionalisierung
richtig und wir waren von anfang an auch
dieser meinung das was sie beschreiben
zu frau merkel ist übrigens ein sehr
starker beleg dafür dass wir hier im
bundestag stärker strategisch
diskutieren müssen denn in der tat die
technischen kompetenzen der
bundeskanzlerin sind klein in dieser
frage trotzdem übt sie politischen druck
will ich gar nicht sagen aber politische
wirkungskraft aus und wenn das die
bundeskanzlerin mit den regierungschefs
der länder kann dann könnte das der
bundestag politisch mit einer klugen
strategie debatte genau so schneider am
zwölfter april vielleicht auch schon
früher ist die nächste runde geplant
sie sitzt mit vielen ministerpräsidenten
darin mit dem vizekanzler und co also
gibt es da schon gespräch haben sich
schon eine ungefähre vorstellung was
sich ändern könnte ja werden gestern
abend dass wir eine abstimmungsrunde wie
die fdp mit ihren landesregierung dass
sich auch macht ich mache mir also es
gibt ja keinen wirklichen ersatz für den
wegfall der osterfeiertage als termin
des instruments und ich muss ihnen
ehrlich sagen angesichts der zahlen der
dynamik der steigenden zahlen
glaube ich ist es gibt eine erschöpfung
aber vielleicht sich die anzahl lage
bewusst und ich würde mal sagen wenn das
über das wochenende weiter so geht muss
man auch vor ostern im zweifel mal
zusammenkommen und handel weil sonst in
zwei wochen verloren das können wir
sicher weise nicht leisten übertragen
übrigens gleich für die zuschauer den rk
ii chef und den gesundheitsminister ab
10 uhr bei phoenix live zu sehen
ich habe schon mal für sie die
schlussfrage ganz schnell wie soll das
denn anders organisiert werden nicht
mehr nachts im kanzleramt da sind sich
alle einig aber sonst
naja man muss seine ideen vorher auf den
tisch legen man muss die prüfungs fähig
machen und nicht spontan mitten in der
nacht mit ganz kleiner runde übermüdet
entscheiden dann kann man die dinge
besser prüfen ergänzen und sie besser
machen und dann kommen vertretbare
vernünftige lösung aus die dann immer
noch politisch möglicherweise umstritten
sind aber nicht so ein chaos anrichten
marco buschmann kassen schneider vielen
dank dass sie da waren sie müssen jetzt
rein